The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: So I've
worked hard over the weekend.
I figured out what I
was doing last time
and what I'm doing this
time and improved the notes.
So you'll get a new set of
notes on the last lecture
and on this one.
And I kind of got a better
picture of what we're doing.
And that board is
aiming to describe
the large picture of what we're
doing last time and this time.
So last time was about changes
in A inverse when A changed.
This time is about changes
in eigenvalues and changes
in singular values
when A change.
As you can imagine, this is a
natural important situation.
Matrices move, and therefore,
their inverses change,
their eigenvalues change,
their singular values change.
And you hope for a formula.
Well, so we did have a
formula for last time
for the change in
the inverse matrix.
And I didn't get every u and
v transpose in the right place
in the video or in the
first version of the notes,
but I hope that that formula,
that that Woodbury Morrison
formula will be
correct this time.
So I won't go back
over that part.
But I realize also there
is another question
that we can answer when
the change is very small,
when the change in A is dA
or delta A, a small change.
And that's, of course,
what calculus is about.
So I have to sort of
parallel topics here.
What is the derivative when
the change is infinitesimal?
And what is the actual change
when the change is finite size?
So now, let me say what we
can do and what we can't do.
Oh, I'll start out by figuring
out what the derivative is
for the inverse.
So that's like
completing the last time
for infinitesimal changes.
Then I'll move on to changes
in the eigenvalues and singular
values.
And there, you cannot
expect an exact formula.
We had a formula that was exact,
apart from any typos, for this.
And we'll find a
formula for this,
and we'll find a formula
for that and for that.
Well, that one will
come from this one.
So this will be a
highlight today.
How do the eigenvalues change
when the matrix changes?
But we won't be able
to do parallel to this,
we won't be able to--
oh, we will be able to do
something for finite changes.
That's important.
Mathematics would have to
keep hitting that problem
until it got somewhere.
So I won't get an exact
formula for that change.
That's too much.
But I'll get inequalities.
How big that change could be.
What can I say about it?
So these are highly interesting.
May I start with completing
the last lecture?
What is the derivative
of the inverse?
So I'm thinking here,
so what's the setup?
The setup is my matrix
A depends on time, on t.
And it has an inverse.
A inverse depends on t.
And if I know this
dependence, in other words,
if I know dA dt, how the
matrix is depending on t,
then I hope I could
figure out what
the derivative of A inverse is.
We should be able to do this.
So let me just start with--
it's not hard and it
complements this one
by doing the calculus case,
the infinitesimal change.
So I want to get to that.
I can figure out
the change in A.
And my job is to find the
derivative of A inverse.
So here's a handy identity.
Can I just put this here?
So here's my usual identity.
So as last time, I start
with a finite change
because calculus always
does that, right.
It starts with a delta
t and then it goes to 0.
So here I am up at
a full size change.
So I think that this is equal to
B inverse A minus B A inverse.
And if it's true, it's
a pretty cool formula.
And, look, it is true, because
over on this right-hand side,
I have B inverse
times A A inverse.
That's the identity.
So that's my B inverse.
And I have the minus, the B
inverse B is the identity.
There's A inverse.
It's good, right?
So from that, well,
I could actually
learn from that the rank of
this equals the rank of this.
That's a point that I
made from the big formula.
But now, we can see it
from an easy formula.
Everywhere here, I'm
assuming that A and B
are invertible matrices.
So when I multiply by
an invertible matrix,
that does not change the rank.
So those have the same ranks.
But I want to get
further than that.
I want to find this.
So how do I go?
How do I go forward
with that job
to find the derivative
of the inverse?
Well, I'm going to call
this a change in A inverse.
And over here, I'll
have B will be--
yeah, OK, let's see, am I right?
Yeah.
So B inverse will be--
this is A plus delta A inverse.
And this is-- well,
that's A minus B. So
that's really minus delta A.
From A to B is the change.
Here, I'm looking at the
difference A minus B.
So it's minus a change.
And here, I have A inverse.
I haven't done anything
except to introduce this delta
and get B out of it
and brought delta in.
Now, I'm going to do calculus.
So I'm thinking of B as
there's a sort of a delta t.
And I'm going to divide
by both sides by delta t.
I have to do this if I want--
and now, I'll let
delta t go to 0.
So calculus appears.
Finally, our-- I won't
say enemy calculus,
but there is a sort
of like competition
between linear
algebra and calculus
for college mathematics.
Calculus has had far, far
too much time and attention.
It like it gets three
or four semesters
of calculus for people who
don't get any linear algebra.
I'm glad this won't be on the
video, but I'm afraid it will.
Anyway, of course, calculus
is fine in its place.
So here's its place.
Now let delta t go to 0.
So what does this
equation become?
Then everybody knows that as
the limit of delta t goes to 0,
I replace deltas by--
so this delta A divided by
delta t that has a meaning.
The top has a meaning and
the bottom has for me.
But then the limit, it's the
ratio that has a meaning.
So dA by itself, I don't
attach a meaning to that.
That's infinitesimal.
It's the limit, so that's why
I wanted a delta over a delta
so I could do calculus.
So what happens now
is delta t goes to 0.
And, of course, as
delta t goes to 0,
that carries delta A to 0.
So that becomes A inverse.
And what does this approach
as delta t goes to 0?
dA dt with that minus sign.
Oh, I've got to
remember the minus sign.
The minus sign is in here.
So I'm bringing
out the minus sign.
Then this was A
inverse, as we had.
And that's dA dt.
And that's A inverse.
That's our formula,
a nice formula,
which sort of belongs
in people's knowledge.
You recognize that if
A was a 1 by 1 matrix,
we could call it x, instead of
A. If A was a 1 by 1 matrix x,
then I'm saying the formula
for the derivative of 1
over x, right?
A inverse just 1 by 1
case is just 1 over x.
So the derivative of 1-- or
maybe t, I should be saying.
If A is just t, then the
derivative of 1 over t with
respect to t is....?
Is minus 1 over t squared.
The 1 by 1 case we know.
That's what calculus does.
And now we're able to
do the n by n case.
So that's just like good.
And then it's sort of parallel
to formulas like this, where
this delta A has not gone to 0.
It's full size, but low rank.
That was the point.
Actually, the formula would
apply if the rank wasn't low.
But the interest is
in low rank here.
Are we good for this?
That's really the completion
of last time's lecture
with derivatives.
OK, come back to here, to
the new thing now, lambdas.
Let's focus on
lambdas, eigenvalues.
How does the eigenvalue change
when the matrix changes?
So I have two possibilities.
One is small change
when I'm doing calculus
and I'm letting a
delta t go to 0.
The other is full
size, order 1 change,
where I will not
be able to give you
a formula for the
new lambdas, but I'll
be able to tell you
important facts about them.
So this is today's lecture now.
You could say that's the
completion of Friday's lecture.
What about d lambda dt?
It's a nice formula.
Its proof is fun too.
I was very happy
about this proof.
OK, so I guess calculus
is showing up here
on this middle board.
So how do I start
with the eigenvalues?
Well, start with what I know.
So these are facts,
you could say,
that I have to get the
eigenvalues into it.
And, of course, eigenvalues
have to come with eigenvectors.
So I'll again use A of t.
It will be depending on t.
And an eigenvector
that depends on t
is an eigenvalue that
depends on t times
and eigenvector
that depends on t.
Good?
That's fact one that we plan to
take the derivative of somehow.
There's also a second fact
that comes into play here.
What's the deal on the
eigenvalues of A transpose?
They are the same.
The eigenvalues of A
transpose are the same
as the eigenvalues of A.
Are the eigenvectors the same?
Not usually.
Of course, if the
matrix was symmetric,
then A and A transpose
are just the same thing.
So A transpose would
have that eigenvalue--
eigenvector.
But, generally, it has
a different eigenvector.
And really to keep a sort
of separate from this one,
let's call it y.
It will have the
same eigenvalue.
I'm going to call it y.
But I'm going to make it a row
vector, because A transpose is
what--
instead of writing
down A transpose,
I'm going to stay with
A, but put the eigenvalue
on the left side.
So here's is the eigenvalue--
eigenvector for A on the left.
And it has the same eigenvalue
times that eigenvector.
But that eigenvector is a
row eigenvector, of course.
This is an equality
between rows.
A row times my
matrix gives a row.
So that's the eigenvalues of--
and it has the same eigenvalues.
So this is totally parallel
to that, totally parallel.
And maybe sort of less--
definitely less
seen, but it's just
the same thing for A transpose.
Everybody sees that if I
transpose this equation,
then I've got something
that looks like that.
But I'd rather have it this way.
Now, one more fact I need.
There is-- there has to
be some normalization.
What should be the
length of these?
Right now, x could
have any length.
y could have any length.
And there's a natural
normalization,
which is y transpose
times x equal to 1.
That normalizes the two.
It doesn't tell me the length
of x or the length of y.
But it tells me, the key
thing, the length of both.
So what I've got there is
tracking along one eigenvalue
and its pair of eigenvectors.
And you're always welcome to
think of the symmetric case
when y and x are the same.
And then I would call them q.
Oh, well, I would call them q
if it was a symmetric matrix.
So if it's a symmetric
matrix, both eigenvectors
would be called q.
And this would be
saying that q is a--
AUDIENCE: Unit vector.
GILBERT STRANG:
Unit vector, right.
So this is all stuff we know.
And actually, maybe I should
write it in matrix notation,
because it's important.
That's for one eigenvector.
This is for all of them at once.
Everybody's with it?
The x's are the columns of x.
And lambda is the diagonal
matrix of lambdas.
And it has to sit on
the right so that it
will multiply those columns.
So this is like all
eigenvectors at once.
What would this one be?
This would be like y
transpose A equals A--
AUDIENCE: y transpose inverse?
GILBERT STRANG: y
transpose, yes--
equals-- and probably
these are multiplied--
I feel wrong if I
write y transpose here.
Like here, the x was on
the right and on the left.
And I'll-- oh, yeah,
y transpose, yeah.
OK, so what do I put?
Lambda y transpose.
Thanks.
And what do I put here?
What does this translate to if
this was for one eigenvector?
For all of them
at once, it's just
going to translate to y
transpose x equal the identity.
This is pretty basic stuff.
But stuff somehow we don't
always necessarily see.
Those are the key facts.
And now, I plan to
take the derivative,
take the derivative
of respect to lambda.
Oh, I can derive one more fact.
So this would be a formula.
This is formula 1.
Formula 1 just says, what do I
get if I hit this on the left
by y transpose?
Can I do that?
y transpose of t A of t x
of t equals lambda of t.
That's a number.
So I can always bring that out
in front of the inner product
of vector notation.
Are you good for that?
I'm pleading like everything
I've done is totally OK.
And now, I have a improvement
to make on this right-hand side,
which is...?
So what is y transpose times x?
AUDIENCE: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: It's 1.
So let's remember that.
It's 1.
So in other words, I have got
a formula for lambda of t.
As time changes,
the matrix changes.
Its eigenvalues change
according to this formula.
Its eigenvectors change
according of this formula.
And its left eigenvectors change
according to that formula.
So everything here
is above board.
And now, what's the point?
The point is I'm going to
find this, the derivative.
So I'm going to take the
derivative of that equation
and see what I get.
That'll be the formula for the
derivative of an eigenvalue.
And amazingly, it's
not that widely known.
Of course, it's classical,
but it's not always
part of courses.
So this is as time varies,
the matrix varies, A.
And therefore, its
eigenvalues vary,
and its eigenvectors vary.
So we're going to
find d lambda dt.
It's one level of
difficulty more
to find dx dt, the
derivative of the eigenvector
or the second derivative
of the eigenvalue.
Those kind of come together.
And I'm not going to go there.
I'm just going to do the
one great thing here--
take the derivative
of that equation.
Shall I do it over there?
So here we go.
So I want to
compute d lambda dt.
And I'm using this
formula for lambda there.
So I've got three
things that depend on t.
And I'm taking the
derivative of their product.
So I'm going to use
the product rule.
I'll apply the product
rule to that derivative.
Take the derivative of the
first guy times A times x.
second guy times the second guy
and the third guy.
y transpose of t A of t dx dt.
OK?
We are one minute away
from a great formula.
And I'm really happy if
you allow me to say it.
That that formula comes
by just taking those facts
we know, putting them
together into this expression
that we also know, and
this is like lambda
equals x inverse Ax.
That's a diagonalizing thing
and then taking the derivative.
So what do I get if I
take that derivative?
Well, this term
I'm going to keep.
I'm not going to play with that.
Everybody is clear?
That's a number.
Here's a matrix.
dA dt is a matrix.
I take the derivative
of every entry in A.
Here's its column
vector, its eigenvector.
And here's a row vector.
So row times matrix times
column is a number, 1 by 1.
And actually, that's my answer.
That's my answer.
So I'm saying that these two
terms cancel each other out
as those two terms
added to zero.
This is the right answer
for the derivative.
That's a nice formula.
So to find the derivative
of an eigenvalue,
the matrix is changing, you
multiply by the eigenvector
and by the left eigenvector.
It gives you a number.
And that's the d lambda dt.
So why do those
two guys add to 0?
That's all that remains here.
And then this topic is ended
with this nice formula.
So I want to simplify that,
simplify that, and show
that they cancel each other.
So what is Ax?
It's lambda x.
So this guy is nothing
but it's lambda
that depends on time of course
times dy dt dy transpose dt.
I'm just copying that.
Ax is lambda x.
Sorry, I didn't mean
to make that look hard.
You OK with that?
Ax is lambda x.
And I am perfectly safe,
because lambda is just a number
to bring it out to the left.
So it doesn't look
like it's in the way.
And what about this other term?
So I have y transpose--
oh, y transpose A, what's that?
What's y transpose A?
That's the combination
that I know.
y transpose A, y is that
left eigenvalue. y transpose
A brings out a lambda.
So this also brings out a lambda
times y transpose times dx dt.
OK?
I just use Ax equal
lambda x there.
It was really nothing.
Now, what do I do?
I want this to be 0.
Can you see it happening?
It's a great pleasure
to see it happening.
So what do I have here?
What's my first step now?
AUDIENCE: Like take lambda--
GILBERT STRANG:
Bring lambda outside.
That's not 0.
We don't know what that is.
Bring lambda outside there
times the whole thing.
So for some wonderful
reason I believe
that this number, which is
a row times a column, a row
times a column,
two terms there, I
believe they knock each other
out and that result is 0.
And why?
Why?
Because I come back to--
this board has all that I know.
And here's y transpose
times x equal 1.
And how does that help me?
Because what I'm seeing in that
square, in those brackets is?
AUDIENCE: The derivative
of y transpose--
GILBERT STRANG: The derivative
of the y transpose x.
So it's the derivative of?
AUDIENCE: 1
GILBERT STRANG: 1.
Therefore, 0.
So this is the derivative of 1.
It equals 0.
Those two terms
knock each other out
and leave just the nice
term that we're seeing.
So the derivative
of the eigenvalue,
just to have one more look
at it before we leave it.
The derivative of the
eigenvalue is this formula.
It's the rate at
which the matrix
is changing times the
eigenvectors on right and left.
Sometimes they're called
the right eigenvector
and the left eigenvector
at the time t.
So we're not saying
in this d lambda dt.
In other words, I
get a nice formula,
which doesn't involve the
derivative of the eigenvector.
That's the beauty of it.
If I want to go up to
take the next step--
I tried this weekend,
but it's a mess.
It would be to take the--
so this is my formula then,
d lambda dt equals this.
And I can take the next
derivative of that,
and it will involve
d second dt squared.
But it will also
involve dx dt and dy dt.
And in fact, a pseudo
inverse even shows up.
It's another step, and I'm not
going that far, because we've
got the best formula there.
So now that has
answered this question.
And I could answer that
question the same way.
It would involve A transpose
A and the singular vectors,
instead of involving A
and the eigenvectors.
Maybe that's a
suitable exercise.
I don't know.
I haven't done it myself.
What I want to do
is this, now say,
what can we say about the
change in the eigenvalue--
and I'll just stay first
of all with eigenvalue--
when the change is like rank 1?
This is a perfect example
when the change is rank 1.
So what can we say
about the eigenvalues--
let's take the top, the largest
eigenvalue, or all of them,
all of them, lambda
j, all of them--
of A plus a rank 1
matrix uv transpose.
Oh, let's do the nice
case here, the nice case,
because if I allow a general
matrix A, I have to worry about
does it have enough
eigenvectors?
Can it diagonalize?
All that stuff.
Let's make it a
symmetric matrix.
And let's make the rank
1 change symmetric too.
So the question is, what can
I say about the eigenvalues
after a rank 1 change?
So again, this
isn't calculus now,
because the change
that I'm making
is a true vector and
not a differential.
And I'm not going to
have an exact formula
for the new
eigenvalues, as I said.
But what I am going to do is
write down the beautiful facts
that are known about that.
And here they are.
So, first of all,
the eigenvalues
are in descending order.
We use descending order
for singular values.
Let's use them also
for eigenvalues.
So lambda 1 is greater
or equal to lambda 2,
greater or equal to
lambda 3, and so on.
Oh, give me-- give me an idea.
What do you expect from
that rank 1 change?
So that change is rank 1.
Can you tell me any more about
that change, u u transpose?
What kind of a matrix
is u u transpose?
It's rank 1, but
we can say more.
It is...?
AUDIENCE: Symmetrical.
GILBERT STRANG:
Symmetric, of course.
And it is...?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Positive semidefinite.
GILBERT STRANG:
Positive semidefinite.
This is a positive change.
u u transpose is the typical
rank 1 positive semidefinite.
It couldn't be
positive definite,
because it's only got rank 1.
What's the eigenvector
of that matrix?
Let's just-- why not here?
We can do this in two seconds.
So u u transpose,
that's the matrix
I'm asking you to think about.
And it's a full n by n
matrix, column times a row.
Tell me an eigenvector
of that matrix.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: u.
GILBERT STRANG: u.
If I multiply my matrix by
u, I get-- what do I get?
I get some number times u.
And what is that number lambda?
AUDIENCE: u transpose u.
GILBERT STRANG: That lambda
happens to be u transpose u.
So that's different
from u u transpose.
This is a matrix.
This is 18.065 now.
That's a number.
And what can you tell
me about that number?
It is...?
AUDIENCE: Greater
than or equal to 0.
GILBERT STRANG: Greater--
well, even more.
Greater than 0.
Greater, because this
is a true vector here.
So this is greater than 0.
It's the only eigenvalue--
all the other eigenvalues
of that rank 1 matrix are zero.
But the one non-zero eigenvalue
is over on the plus side.
It's u transpose u.
We all recognize that as
the length of u squared.
It's certainly positive.
So we do have a positive
semidefinite definite matrix.
What would your guess be of the
effect on the eigenvalues of A?
So I'm coming back
to my real problem--
eigenvalues of S,
sorry, S. Symmetric
matrices, I'm saying symmetric.
What is your guess if I
have a symmetric matrix
and I add on u u transpose?
What do you imagine that
does to the eigenvalues?
You're going to get it right.
Just say it.
What happens to the eigenvalues
of S if I add on u u transpose?
They will...?
AUDIENCE: More positive.
GILBERT STRANG: They'll
be more positive.
They'll go up.
This is a positive thing.
It's like adding
17 to something.
It moves up.
So therefore, what
I believe is--
so I've got two sets
of eigenvalues now.
One is the eigenvalues of s.
The other is the different
eigenvalues of S.
So I can't call them both
lambdas or I'm in trouble.
So do you have a favorite
other Greek letter
for the eigenvalues of S?
AUDIENCE: Gamma.
GILBERT STRANG: Gamma.
OK, gamma.
As long as you
say a Greek letter
that I have some
idea how to write.
Zeta, it seems to me, is like
the world's toughest letter
to write.
And electrical engineers
can coolly flush off a zeta.
I've never succeeded.
So I'll write--
what did you say?
AUDIENCE: Gamma.
GILBERT STRANG: Gamma
j of the original.
So those are the
eigenvalues of the original.
These are the eigenvalues
of the modified.
And we're expecting the lambdas
to be bigger than the gammas.
So that's just a
qualitative statement.
And it's true.
Each lambda is bigger
than the gamma.
Sorry, yeah, yeah, each
lambda, by adding this stuff,
the lambdas are bigger than--
so I'll just write that.
Lambdas are bigger than gammas.
And that's a fundamental
fact, which we could prove.
But a little more is known.
Of course, the question
is, how much bigger?
How much can they be way bigger?
Well, I don't believe
they could be bigger
by more than that number myself.
But there's just
better news than that.
So the lambdas are
bigger than the gammas.
So lambda 1 is
bigger than gamma 1.
So this is the S plus
u u transpose matrix.
And these are the
eigenvalues of the S matrix.
Lambda 1 is bigger than gamma 1.
But look what's happening
in this line of text here.
I'm saying that gamma 1--
that lambda 2 is
smaller than gamma 1.
Isn't that neat?
The eigenvalues go up.
But they don't just
like go anywhere.
And that's called interlacing.
So this is one of those
wonderful theorems that
makes your heart happy, that
if I do I rank one change
and it's a positive change,
then the eigenvalues increase,
but they don't increase--
the new eigenvalue is below
the new second eigenvalue.
It doesn't pass up the
old, first eigenvalues.
And the new third
eigenvalue doesn't pass up
the old second eigenvalue.
So that's the
interlacing theorem
that's associated with the
names of famous math guys.
And of course you have
to say that's beautiful.
While we're writing
down such a theorem,
make a guess of what
the theorem would
be if I do a rank 2 change.
Suppose I do an S,
staying symmetric.
And I do a rank 1 change.
But then I also do a rank 2
change, say w w transpose.
So what's the deal here?
What do I know about the change
matrix, the delta S here?
I know its rank is 2.
I'm assuming u and w are
not in the same direction.
So that's a rank 2 matrix.
And what can you tell me about
the eigenvalues of that rank 2
matrix?
So it's got n eigenvalues
because it's an n by n matrix.
But how many non-zero
eigenvalues has it got?
Two, because its rank is 2.
The rank tells you the number
of non-zero eigenvalues
when matrices are symmetric.
It doesn't tell you enough.
If matrices are unsymmetric,
eigenvalues can be weird.
So stay symmetric here.
So this has two
non-zero eigenvalues.
And can you tell me their sign.
Is that matrix
positive semidefinite?
Yes, of course, it is.
Of course.
So this was and this was.
And together it certainly is.
So now, I've added a rank 2
positive semidefinite matrix.
And now, I'm not going
to rewrite this line,
but what would you
expect to be true?
You would expect that
the eigenvalues increase.
But how big could gamma--
yeah, so gamma 2,
let's follow gamma 2.
Well, maybe I
should use another--
do the Greeks have any other
letters than lambda and gamma.
They must had--
AUDIENCE: Zeta.
GILBERT STRANG: Who?
C?
Hell with that.
Who knows one I can write?
AUDIENCE: Alpha.
GILBERT STRANG: Alpha.
Good, alpha.
Yes, alpha.
Right.
So alpha is the eigenvalues
of this rank 2 change.
OK.
Now, what am I going
to be able to say?
Can I say anything about the--
well, of course, alpha 1
is bigger than lambda 1,
which was bigger than--
eigenvalues are going up, right?
I'm adding positive definite
or positive semidefinite stuff.
There's no way eigenvalues
can start going down on me.
So alpha 1 is a greater
or equal to the lambda
1, which had just a
rank 1 change, which
is greater or equal to the--
mu, was it mu?
AUDIENCE: Gamma.
GILBERT STRANG: Gamma.
Gamma 1, and so on.
OK, now, let's see, is
gamma 1 bigger than alpha--
what am I struggling
to write down here?
What could I say?
Well, what can I
say that reflects
the fact that this lambda 2--
or sorry, so gamma 1 went up.
Gamma 1 was bigger
than lambda 2.
That was the point here.
Gamma 1 is bigger.
So this was a sort of easy,
because I'm adding stuff.
I expected the lambda to go up.
This is where the theorem
is that it didn't go up
so far as to pass--
or sorry, the lambda
2, which went up,
didn't pass up gamma 1.
Lambda 2 didn't pass up gamma 1.
And now let me write
those words down.
Now the alpha 2--
well, could alpha
2 pass up lambda 1?
And what about alpha 3?
Let me say what I believe.
I think alpha 2, which is like
1 behind, but I'm adding rank 2,
I think alpha 2 could
pass up lambda 1.
It could pass lambda 1.
But alpha 3 can't.
I believe that alpha 3 is
smaller than lambda 1--
smaller than gamma
1, the original.
Got it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Anyway, I'll get it
right in the notes.
You know what
question I'm asking.
And for me, that's
the important thing.
Now, there is a little
matter of why is this true?
This is the good case.
Let me give you another
example of interlacing.
Can I do that?
It really comes
from this, but let
me give you another example
that's just striking.
So I have a symmetric
matrix, n by n.
Call it S. And then I throw
away the last row and column.
So in here is S n minus 1.
The big matrix was Sn.
This one is of size n minus 1.
So it's got sort of
less degrees of freedom,
because the last degree
of freedom got removed.
And what do you think
about the eigenvalues
of the n minus 1
eigenvalues of this
and the n eigenvalues of that?
They interlace.
So this has eigenvalue lambda 1.
This would have an
eigenvalue smaller than that.
eigenvalue lambda 2.
This would have an eigenvalue
smaller than that and so on.
Just the same
interlacing and basically
for the same reason,
that when you--
this reduction to
size n minus 1 is
like I'm saying xn has
to be 0 in the energy
or any of those expression.
And the fact of making xn be 0
is like one constraint, taking
one degree of freedom away.
It reduces the eigenvalues,
but not by two.
OK, now I have
one final mystery.
And let me try to tell you what.
It worried me.
Now what is it that worried me?
Yes, suppose this change, this
u, this change that I'm making,
suppose it's actually the
second eigenvector of S.
So can I write this down?
Suppose u is actually the
second eigenvector of S.
What do I mean by that?
So I mean that S times
u is lambda 2 times u.
Now, I'm going to change it.
S plus u u transpose, that's
what I've been looking at.
And that moves the
eigenvalues up.
But what worries me is
like if I multiply this
by 20, some big
number, I'm going
to move that eigenvalue
way up, way past.
I got worried about
this inequality.
When I add this, that same
u is lambda 2 plus 20 u.
Su is lambda 2u.
And this 20 is 20.
u is a unit vector.
So you see my worry?
Here, I'm doing a rank 1 change.
But it's moved an
eigenvalue way, way up.
So how could this
statement be true?
So I've just figured
out here what gamma--
well, do you see my question?
I could leave it as a
question to answer next time.
Let me do that.
And I'll put it online
so you'll see it clearly.
It looks like and it happens
this eigenvector now has
eigenvalue lambda 2 plus 20.
Why doesn't that blow
away this statement?
I'll put that, because it's sort
of coming with minus 10 seconds
to go in the class, so let's
leave that and a discussion
of this for next time.
But I'm happy with this
lecture if you are.
Last lecture I got
u's and v's mixed up.
And it's not reliable.
Here, I like the
proof of the lambda dt
and we're started
on this topic 2.
Good.
Thank you.